bonsoir alors parlez-moi de cette femme
que vous avez au cours des années
a pris à connaître très bien
je l'ai rencontré la première fois en
1977 j'ai eu l'occasion de l'accompagner
à l'occasion des fêtes du centenaire et
puis après ça j'ai eu bien bien des
occasions de la rencontrer aussi bien
comme Ménès ou comme premier ministre
d'ailleurs j'avais passé à 70
1970 4 jours et demi avec elle le prince
Philippe la prince Charles la princesse
Sam dans le Grand Nord canadien avec
Aline pour célébrer les
fêtes et on a passé dans tous les
villages c'était vraiment intéressant
parlé avec les autochtones et tout ça
parler de leurs travaux de leur vie et
elle était très très agréable pour
parler comme j'étais seule avec elle
dans l'avion et prince Philippe parce
que alien devait être dans un autre
avion avec le prince Charles qui était
l'héritier et la princesse Anne alors
et nous parlions en français parce
qu'elle disait c'était une occasion pour
elle de pratiquer son français et
c'était la même chose pour la presse
Philippe parce qu'on porte il y avait
pas autant l'occasion de parler notre
langue que qu'il avait eu dans le passé
alors j'ai eu bien des incidents avec
elle et des rencontres aussi bien comme
un Noël et alors j'ai énormément de
souvenirs oui elle se tenait au courant
monsieur elle connaissait bien les
méandres de la politique canadienne puis
des pièges puis des défis et tout ça
elle a
donc elle est-ce qu'elle vous
questionnez vous sentiez que suivait le
débat politique au Canada
très bien parce que quand vous
rencontrez la reine et que vous êtes un
grand Bretagne je l'ai rencontré dans
quatre châteaux différents et avant de
rencontre pour s'asseoir pour le lundi
on doit avoir une rencontre privée avec
la reine où on discute de l'état des
affaires dans le pays qui fait partie du
commonwald et quand nous n'avions ces
discussions là il était très très au
courant d'ailleurs un moment donné ce
qui est assez intéressant c'est que
j'étais
durant
1985 au moment du faire référendum un
comédien chez nous c'était fait possible
pour Jean-Chrétien il y avait réussi à
l'avoir sur les gens il y avait tenu des
propos difficiles très drôles et avec
des mots qu'elle ne puisse parfois s'il
y a un point des mots je comment on dit
de joie et puis et elle avait gardé son
calme et elle avait répondu
et quand je l'ai vu quelques jours après
à réunion du commonwalto en
Nouvelle-Zélande monsieur excusé à la
reine je m'excuse Votre Majesté pour ce
qui vous est arrivé l'audio a dit elle
m'a dit je pensais que vous étiez
ivre
le flegme britannique secrétien est-ce
que
[Musique]
70 ans de règles on verra peut-être plus
jamais ça en fait sûrement plus jamais
ça c'est quand même une fille elle a
élevée on a l'impression la monarchie un
autre niveau la légende puis on le voit
à Londres les gens sont tristes même ici
au Québec là il y a des gens qui
disaient moi sans être
monarchiste j'appréciais la femme
très très agréable
et puis le mari aussi alors non moi j'ai
eu des souvenirs extrêmement heureux
avec elle et elle était dans partout
quand je voyageais comme premier
ministre des réunions du commonwalt elle
était toujours
reçu avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme même
des dans des endroits où les gens comme
vous disiez tantôt que c'était pas
particulièrement à monarchiste comme en
Nouvelle-Zélande
la réception de la personne est a
toujours fantastique
quand je voyageais à l'international les
deux personnes qui recevaient la
meilleure réception c’était elle et
Nelson Mandela
nous étions à quelque part avec Nelson
Mandela aucun d'entre nous existait tous
les yeux étaient sur Nelson Mandela je
vais poser la même chose pour la reine
avant de vous laisser aller monsieur
chrétien je viens de parler à votre
collègue Marionnet qui disait qui disait
dans l'apartheid elle a eu une influence
c'est à Dieu vous est-ce que d'après
vous elle avait parce que elle voit le
Premier ministre britannique à chaque
semaine elle a pas de pouvoir comme j'ai
tout à l'heure est-ce que elle peut
avoir de l'influence politique dans son
pays ailleurs d'après vous
certainement très discrètement
on se lève les problèmes et elle vous
pose des questions vous donner des
réponses et l'homme un peu dit peut-être
que vous êtes-vous sûr que vous êtes
dans la bonne voie ou je discutais à
plusieurs reprises la situation de
l'unité du Canada pour elle c'était
primordial ça va qu'est-ce qui se passe
et elle faisait des commentaires qui
étaient utiles
on savait qu'elle était bien informée et
que tout ce qu'elle souhaitait c'est que
chacun des pays du commonwealt réussi
quand le travailler jusqu'à la fin le
présenter la nouvelle Première ministre
il y a deux jours à 96 ans
jean-chrétiens merci beaucoup de nous
avoir parlé ce soir c'est un peu plaisir
merci beaucoup de m'avoir invité à
bientôt au revoir